[Music]
[Music]
since this withdrawal into itself or
self-centeredness of the existent
consciousness immediately makes itself
discordant evil appears as the primary
existence of the inwardly turned
consciousness and because the thoughts
of good
and evil are utterly opposed and this
antithesis is not yet resolved this
consciousness is essentially
only evil
but at the same time on account of just
this antithesis there is also present
the good consciousness opposing it and
their relations to each other
insofar as an immediate existence
suddenly changes into thought and the
being within self is on the one hand of
thinking well on the other hand the
moment of the othering of essence is
more precisely determined by it because
of this double aspect the becoming of
evil can be shifted further back out of
the existent world even into the primary
realm of thought
it can therefore be said that it is the
very first born son of light lucifer
himself who fell because he withdrew
into himself or became self-centered but
that in his place another was at once
created such a form of expression has
fallen which like the expression sun
belongs moreover to picture thinking and
not to the notion
degrades the moments of the notion to
the level of the picture thinking or
carries picture thinking over into the
realm of thought
likewise it makes no difference if we
coordinate a multiplicity of other
shapes with the simple thought of
otherness in the eternal being and
transfer the self-centeredness into them
in fact this coordination must be
approved since by means of it this
moment of otherness also expresses
diversity as it should and moreover not
as plurality in general but also as a
specific diversity so that the one part
the sun is that which is simple and
knows itself to be essential being while
the other part is the alienation the
externalization of being for self which
lives only
to praise that being
so this part then can be assigned the
taking back again of the externalized
being for self and the withdrawal into
self of the evil principle
insofar as the otherness falls into two
parts spirit might as regards its
moments if these are to be counted be
more exactly expressed as a quaternity
in unity or because the quantity itself
again falls into two parts that is one
part which has remained good and the
other which has become evil might even
be expressed as a five in one
but to count the moments can be reckoned
as altogether useless since in the first
place what can be differentiated is
itself just as much only one thing that
is the thought of the difference which
is only one thought as if the
differentiated is this differentiated
element the second relatively to the
first
and secondly it is useless to count
because the thought which grasped the
many in a one must be dissolved out of
its universality and differentiated into
more than three or four distinct
components and this universality appears
in contrast to the absolute
determinateness of the abstract unit the
principle of number as indeterminateness
with respect to number as such
so that we could speak only of numbers
in general that is not of a specific
number of differences
here therefore it is quite superfluous
to think of numbers and counting it all
just as in other respects the mere
difference of quantity an amount has no
notional significance and makes no
difference
paragraph
776 there's a lot going on in this long
paragraph if we wanted to be a little
facetious we could say that there's a
lot of moving parts and why do i say
that would be facetious because we see
hegel talking about this you know
possible quaternity
or
five in unity with its different parts
and and you know they can't be
just parts is
a portion of the the little joke that
we're making here which probably isn't
all that funny but you know about as
good as you're going to get out of
handle stuff
so a lot happening here on the heels of
the previous paragraphs there is a bit
of what kind of feels like a digression
we'll see why
it's not exactly a digression if we read
between the lines about the point that's
been made over and over again about
picture thinking
and notional
thinking
for stellan representation or picture
thinking and then the concept or notion
the grip right and
uh you know conceptual thinking
and
there's you know that's that's going to
be important as it's going to turn out
but in a different way and i think it's
good that he's making the
examples that he is you know we've seen
previous examples of talking about
father and son
and the garden of eden
you know human beings screwing things up
these are all examples of picture
thinking so we'll talk about that in a
moment because we get some new
bits of picture thinking here right we
have uh
lucifer the very first born son of light
but let's let's get there first so this
uh
paragraph begins by talking about
here in the translation since this
withdrawal into itself or
self-centeredness of the existent
consciousness
immediately makes itself discordant and
you know the the key term there is
actually
withdrawal into self
insight gayan
this is interesting
because a little bit later in the
passage we're going to have
in zeke zein
not on zeke zion which we've seen over
and over again you know being in itself
or intrinsic being is sometimes how it
gets translated
this is different on and in are not
exactly the same this is an interiority
that we're talking about
here with withdrawal into itself in
that makes sense again you know to go
right to go into
its own
self
and
um
self-centeredness is just adding some
extra stuff to this of the existent
consciousness the
which is what we're going to begin with
here but before that
i think it's good to point out this this
really rich term that hegel's using here
self-discordant
it it uh as he says here
makes it
self-discordant okay so there is a
transformation that's taking place
zeke zelpst right two intensifiers uh
you know self-self you could say
like
we'll come back to that in a moment and
then verden uh rather than zion vered
and becoming the
the transformation of itself into
something that is okay so
discordant wouldn't like does that work
yes
unequal as well
um not corresponding to each other and
this is going to be
really important hold on to that because
when we get to this multiplicity of
shapes and also when we're thinking
about good and evil
this unlike is not simply like a equal
sign with the slash through it they're
just not the same thing
and
discordant kind of captures it we need
to think about what
discordance
really is in order to draw all the
meaning
out of this when we have a discord in
music
you know when you're listening to a
chord
and then it gets transformed a little
bit some of the notes get you know
raised or lowered or maybe warped right
and you're like oh that doesn't sound so
great dissonance is often how we talk
about it
something a greater unity but also an
organization
has
been
lost or
bent or
broken or abandoned now of course you
could say well wait a second in the
history of music we have all sorts of
cases where what was originally
discordant to us in the present sounds
really cool
yes that that's true but it's because
we're responding to having worked
through that sound at first it was like
oh that's awful don't don't do that
right
so
let's go on with with this
we start as he says
with evil
evil appears as the
primary existence
airstep right first existence the first
dozen
of the inwardly turned consciousness
um
okay so how is evil
appearing as existence it is realizing
this is consciousness it is
self-consciousness too
it is realizing itself the existent
consciousness within this antithesis
that now
is available to it of the good versus
the evil that we saw brought in in the
last paragraph it's left the realm of
innocence
and he says um
because the thoughts of good and evil
are utterly opposed
i mean utterly opposed is
a little bit of a hyperbole there
they're ant gag and gazettes right um
they're opposed to each other and
there's an end gigan zetsung a
opposition or if you like antithesis
being involved here not quite as you
know strong as a gegenzotz uh
contradiction right but uh they're
they're opposed and because this
antithesis is not yet resolved now
notice this is a really interesting part
this consciousness
is essentially only
evil
but at the same time
because of this antithesis there is also
present the good consciousness opposing
it
and their relation of antithesis to each
other okay we've got to pause here
because there's a lot happening in this
spot it has to do with this
self-discordant becoming
so
let's take up the the easiest part first
right the okay if there's a
consciousness that is conscious of
itself
as evil
in being conscious of that it is
conscious of another consciousness which
is also
perhaps a possibility for itself a good
consciousness that it is not right
there's an other
going on here and this fits in perfectly
with you know what we know about
self-consciousness from a hegelian
perspective that self-consciousness is
self-consciousness in relation to
another's self-consciousness and in this
case one is good one is evil the one
that i am at this point is evil and the
other one is good and maybe i have some
inkling what that means maybe i
understand it is just not being me right
the good one doesn't necessarily here at
this point understand the evil
consciousness maybe that's just kind of
an absurdity or foolishness to it but
the evil can understand
the good and it's it's relation as hegel
says it's bizeal to
it
so there's you could say
epistemologically a primacy
of the
evil consciousness
and
why is this
evil consciousness evil to go a little
bit ahead
and to say something about
hegel and good and evil in general
um
hegelian ethics is you know very much
about like recognition that's a key idea
there but another key
thing
is being part of a
vast
system in which you have your legitimate
place when you do legitimate tasks
and you have the truth of your existence
as part of the truth of the whole rather
than you
exploiting the whole or parts of the
whole or taking advantage of it or
reacting against it setting yourself
apart that's part of what's evil and
this is something that the
hegelians
going all the way into like the 20th
century british hegelians
will
stress as part of the hegel idealist
ethics you know
point of view so to become aware of
yourself as an existent individual and
as we've seen it earlier in the
morality section as an individual with
your own
interpretations of things as an
individual motivated by your own desires
who you know gets the you know the
categorical imperative or the rules that
you're supposed to follow and you're
like why the hell should i do this
well that makes you evil right at least
in in in this sense and so evil is
becoming kind of like part of what it is
to
to exist
so
essentially
only evil is the phrase that he uses
here
so
we have at the same time you know the
good consciousness and then hegel takes
us in a different direction so so far
we've been thinking about the human
being
right the human being becomes aware of
themselves as evil okay we look at the
previous paragraph garden of eden we
left it we have knowledge of good and
evil but god is good at least right
well
maybe there's some evil in god too
or in the divine and the eternal at
least
so he says
in so far
as immediate existence
the existent consciousness right
um
suddenly changes
into
thought
and the being within self
and and this again is
in design
right not on zeke sign
the being within self is on the one hand
of thinking well on the other hand the
moment of the othering of essence
is more precisely
determined by it right so we've got a
what's going on in in what's going to be
called the realm of thought in just a
moment we have being within self as part
of that
in zeek sign
and we have othering
on design
of essence a vason
those are both sides to what's happening
in the thought
so
he goes on and he says because of this
double aspect that's miller's gloss the
becoming of evil
that's a very interesting term isn't it
especially since
where is verdin showing up before this
zeke zelps
verdan right this the the withdrawal
into itself become is a becoming
self-discordant now we have the becoming
of evil
right
uh the the development the entrance into
the world of
evil the fl
maybe flourishing the the
uh unpacking
of this thing that we're we're viewing
as evil that is viewing itself as evil
but now shifting away from the
individual existent consciousness into
something more universal something more
abstract perhaps even
the eternal that is the divine
so he goes on and he says
the becoming of evil can be shifted
further back out of the existent world
right in the previous paragraphs we got
world we got
individual human self we've got a god up
there right
and so now we're shifting out of that up
into
the realm of thought the reich the the
denkins
and
what are we what are we gonna have here
now here's where he starts to talk about
some picture thinking
ideas and so you know what are these he
says it can therefore be said that it is
the very first born son of light you
know gloss here lucifer himself who fell
why
he withdrew into himself or became
self-centered he did an insic game right
and by doing so became discord and you
know
how exactly did that take place well
there's different origin stories of the
devil right it could you know think
about saint anselm
he's got a whole book called on the fall
of the devil and it's him and one of his
best students sort of you know going
back and forth and trying to figure this
thing out and you know in the end
they're like well
isn't god on the hook for this because
he made the devil the way he is and they
they reason to the point that whereas
like no
the devil chose something that wasn't
bad for him to choose per se but he
shouldn't have chosen at that time
that would be one sort of portrayal of
the indian that hegel is talking about
here
namely to be like god right
to have an autonomous will propria
volontas in in anselm coming back to
hegel he says uh
in his place another was at once created
who's who's that other well the human
beings
because it wasn't just lucifer fell the
other fallen angels and human beings
will take their place we're in the realm
of all sorts of picture thinking
you know four gestelt um
conjectures on the part of religious
people it was specifically within
christianity for the most part i mean i
think you can find this outside as well
but a lot of christian theology
particularly in the middle ages was very
interested in this topic of human the
good human beings replacing the fallen
angels
picture thinking from hegel's
perspective right and we can go on
further
such a form of expression as fallen
which like the expression sun
belongs to picture thinking and not to
the notion
okay so here we have a you know sort of
a classificatory thing
picture thinking representation not bad
in and of itself as a matter of fact it
can lead people towards the notion which
is where we want to go
but
there can be a danger of remaining
with it right thinking that it's
adequate
and so he says
what does this do it degrades the
moments of the notion to the level of
picture thinking
keep that in mind when we get to the
stuff that we're going to talk about
in just a couple minutes or
it carries picture thinking over into
the realm of thought
both of these are a problem right we
have this sort of uh
degree degradation or reduction of
the notion which somebody's worked out
to picture thinking
and picture thinking just can't support
what the notion provides
or we're bringing into the notion we're
bringing into the realm of thought the
higher realm of thought the structures
of picture thinking which are again
going to cause some some problems
so he says
likewise it makes no difference if we
coordinate
right
and this is going to be quite important
by organ is going to be the
the noun here
um if we coordinate a multiplicity of
other shapes right so
hegel's talking here about
gestalton
um
are we talking about gestalted in the
full sense of like okay here's a stage
of consciousness no
but it's more than just forms or moments
or something like that and this is a
monog faulty kite right and to go back
to what i said in in some of the
previous paragraphs
um we have to remember that when we're
talking about like you know god and
human consciousness human consciousness
is not just a single individual
consciousness it is a whole bunch of uh
individual consciousnesses uh living in
a social world together connected to
each other in complex relations
it's not
very simple and so we've got a
multiplicity of manic faulty kite here
and the question is well what kind of
multiplicity are we working with
so he says
makes no difference if we coordinate a
multiplicity of other shapes with the
simple thought
of otherness in the eternal being right
the other ring of essence
and transfer the self-centeredness the
being within self the in zeek sign into
them
and then he says in fact this
coordination
must be approved this by ordnance right
and it's not just an ordnung a
ordering
it's
think of the by here as sort of an
intensification
sort of like the fear that often gets
used in german to to indicate that
there's something interesting happening
here this coordination must be approved
since by means of this
this mo
of it this moment of otherness
also expresses and now we've got a
couple different terms coming up it
expresses diversity as it should
and moreover notice this clarification
not as a plurality in general but as a
specific diversity
so we have
two
connected you know
ideas here
signified by different words
feel height is plurality you know uh
there being more than one right there
being a many feel right
um
and demonic faulty kite is by its you
know
uh very nature a feel height isn't it
you know a manifold a multiplicity it
has to be a plurality
but this is different fair sheed in
height right a
more coordinated more
selected you could say diversity not
just like laying a bunch of cards on the
table but saying how the cards are
connected to each other
so he goes on and he s he starts
unpacking this right we have the sun
and uh what is the sun that which is
simple and knows itself to be the
essential being okay great so we got
anything here
or an aspect
and on the other part is the alienation
the externalization of being for self
which lives only to praise that thing
cool now we got two things right we got
the sun and the alienation sort of like
we've got being within self and we've
got the othering of that essence and in
this case the othering of that essence
has its own kind of you know agency it's
going to praise the sun cool now we've
got a duality
here's where it gets really kind of
weird
because hegel is going to now break this
second part down into two parts
and he says um
[Music]
here we go to this part
can be assigned the taking back of the
externalized being for self
okay taking back the externalized being
for self is a part of this
alienation or externalization and also
the withdrawal into self of the evil
principle so now we've got two things in
the
alienation side
now
where is he getting four from it's as if
he's reading
these things as
four when we really would say you've got
two and part of the two is broken down
into a further two that should amount to
three and you know i mean that's right
but maybe
that's there to
suggest to us what hegel is going to
tell us about numbers in a bit they
don't matter
don't get all worked up about numbers
because you're losing the point there
because look at the next thing that he
says
insofar as the otherness falls into two
parts spirit might as regards its
moments if these are to be
counted more be more exactly expressed
as a quaternity in unity or because the
quantity and quantity there is a
translation of manga the crowd the the
lot you could say
it's not an actual quantity itself falls
into two parts one part which is remain
good and the other which has become evil
it might even be expressed as a five and
one and now you could say okay we need
to really spend a lot of time here
figuring out exactly how these
divisions and calculations take place
and if you want to do that more power to
you you know you can also see this as
hegel is just kind of showing you what
he's going to talk about in a minute the
futility the pointlessness of doing
precisely
that because what does he say next
he tells us that
to count the moments zelen right
zalin means to number
because immediately after this hegel is
going to talk about numbers dalin right
so zelen is to number things
and he tells us that counting
is
useless unutz it's not helpful
it's a waste of our time
you might even say it's a distraction
why
he says
to count the moments can be reckoned as
altogether useless why in the first
place what is differentiated is itself
just as much only one thing the the
thought
of the difference which is only one
thought
as it the differentiated is this
differentiated element the second
relatively to the first so
here hegel is saying listen
parse it up however you want still a
unity and that's part of what matters
here so your numbering is numbering the
same thing right second
he says
it's useless to count because the
thought which grasped the many in a one
must be dissolved out of its
universality and differentiated into
more
than three or four distinct components
okay
so there's not enough you got to go
further with this
yes
but we also need to get away from the
abstract
and towards the
you know more particular relations that
these
these aspects have with each other so
like he says
this universality appears in contrast to
the absolute determinateness of the
abstract unit the principle
of number
right
as indeterminateness with respect to
number as such
so that we could speak only of numbers
in general not of a specific number
of differences
here therefore who's bringing this to a
close
it is quite superfluous to think of
numbers and counting at all just as in
other respects the mere difference of
quantity and amount has no
notional significance and makes no
difference so what is hegel saying here
worrying about the numbers here
it's not as if numbers are bad or
anything like that
but it's another kind of picture
thinking
it doesn't use pictures it uses numbers
it uses counting and stuff like that but
just because you're not using images
doesn't mean that you're not doing um
for stellum right it's not adequate to
the notion
of the divine and of the human
consciousness that is grasping
the divine so this is i think a really
really
important
little section of the phenomenology that
because it's quite complex and difficult
i think a lot of people be tempted to
you know read through quick and then be
like i'll come back to this and it'll
make more sense later and it will make
more sense later as you read the next
paragraphs but this is one that we
really really need to
linger over as we have just done
you